نحن هنا في
المقر الرئيسي لشركة Microsoft في واشنطن حيث أعلنت الشركة للتو عن
إصدار محدث من
محرك بحث Bing ومتصفح الويب Edge باستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي.
أكثر قوة ، لذا دعنا نجربها ،
أنا هنا مع الساق كومار ، إنها تعمل مع
فرق البحث في Microsoft ، هذا صحيح ،
لذا يمكننا تحديدًا نوعًا ما أن
نوضح لنا كيف سيعمل هذا من دواعي سروري ،
لذا ربما سأقوم بذلك  نيكاراغوا في غضون
أسبوعين ، أحتاج إلى أنه
لا يزال لدينا البحث الذي
يعرفه الجميع تمامًا كما لو أنك حصلت على
مجموعة الروابط الخاصة بك على الجانب الأيسر
ولكن ما تراه الآن مع
newbing هو أننا نأخذ المحتوى الذي
احصل بالفعل على البحث ثم
نلخصه بناءً على الموجه الذي
حصلنا عليه ، ثم
أعطيني أمثلة على المطاعم
الرائعة وروابط لها جميعًا ،
حسنًا ، لذلك هناك مجموعة من
الأشياء المختلفة التي يمكننا استخدامها من أجلها  هذا صحيح
ليس فقط لتخطيط الرحلة ،
لذا ربما سنحاول
مثالًا مختلفًا إذا كان هذا جيدًا ، لذلك
أقول فقط أن الموضوع الجديد ، اكتب لي
خطة وجبة نباتية للأسبوع الذي
تذهب إليه ، لقد حصلت على
خطة وجبات نباتية جيدة  نعم ، إنه يعطيني
كل يوم
اكتب لي قائمة البقالة حسب
قسم البقالة لخطة الوجبة ، دعنا نذهب لنرى
رائعًا جدًا ، آمل أن يساعدك هذا في
التسوق لمحلات البقالة الخاصة بك ، أنا متأكد من أنه
سيصحيح إرسال
بريد إلكتروني
إلى صديقي
بما في ذلك
هذا حسنًا  لا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، هذا الأنبوب
أداة جديدة قوية ولكن لا تزال هناك
أسئلة حول سلامته في الأيام الأولى ،
ودقة الطريقة التي يستخدمها بها الأشخاص ،
وتقول Microsoft إنها تفكر
في كل هذه الأشياء ، ولكن في النهاية
يمكن أن يغير هذا الطريقة التي نقوم بها عبر الإنترنت
يبحث